en lançant sa vous décroche un vrai
supporter s'élève et sa part en chantant
un enfant avec un peu de chance sentence
il en faveur des diamants
j'appelle comment est née cette chanson
mais elle n'est pas née en cotisations
elle est à naître j'en avais beaucoup
pas ça est ce que vous savez d'avancé
une chanson marchera pas ce stade là il
faut que ce soit plus leur marché je
sais si l atmosphère marché voilà se
poursuivre parce que pour vous les
sentiers sont sur ma faim si aujourd'hui
c'est voter comment expliquez vous cette
connivence entre le public et vous parce
que c'est même pas un accord cette
espèce de de jeu du extraordinaire qui
démarre dès que vous prononcez les
premières paroles la fin vous sentez
bien sûr n'ont pas bien non plus tant
que ça ah oui et non
non sens pour ça sans qui tout à fait
autre chose contre je trouve que c'est
très centré bonzesses quoi voile et ils
sont très ça devient très féminin l
asala le public est très faible
ce pas j'ai l'impression dé viol est un
petit peu par moment mais ils sont pas
de connivence femmes et de quoi de
regrets dans 10 de ce sacré différence
qu'il ya entre les choses quand est ce
qu'on réalise qu'il entend quand
derrière air france
on n'est pas sûr d'avoir raté ça quand
même
ça n'est tout ça c'est pas triste croyez
quoi comment comment triste d'affiché
chance aux normes j'écrivais des
chansons nous sommes mais c'est pas
triste non
vous me parlez comme un gars qui fait du
cap coz en 1900 mêlant mais j'ai réussi
quoi quand je lis rimbaud et que
j'écoute le quatuor de ravel
j'ai tout raté même non plus c'est ce
n'est pas des gens je ne pleure pas
qu'est ce que j'ai réussi on ne réussit
jamais que par rapport à ce qu'on commet
comprenez ce que je veux dire je
freinais à vannes et les mouiller en
je serai très fier est conscient de
cette magnifique réussite mais c'est
impossible d compenser un peu un corner
on lit le bateau ivre djoudi le quatuor
de debussy la voiture de rallye
daphnis et chloé puis après j'entends
chansonnette d'un gars qui s'appelle
bein je trouve ça bien ce qui je trouve
qu'ils se prostituent pas trop enfin je
suis quand même j'ai pas la tête il à se
mettre à gonfler à moucher comme
s'affronter des arrêts comme ça ne
m'atteint bien payé ça n'est pas très
sérieux
j'ai pas je n'ai pas honte mais une
grande île où le repac constitution n'y
a pas de prostitution
non ou alors c'est gratuit